- So the January 6 Committee
may have uncovered some
pretty serious crimes.
After nearly a year of
investigating the January 6th attack
on the US Capitol, the House
Select Committee has started
to present their findings
to the American people
in a series of televised hearings.
Since it's formation,
the committee has conducted
over a thousand interviews
and reviewed more than 140,000 documents.
The committee has also issued
more than a hundred subpoenas
for testimony and documents
as part of its inquiry,
from a variety of individuals,
including Republican members of Congress,
former Trump White House
officials, outside Trump allies,
like Roger Stone and Alex Jones
and white nationals figures
who've promoted false election claims.
The committee has presented a
trove of evidence suggesting
that the Trump White House
not only deliberately
undermined American democracy,
but might have committed
crimes in the process.
And the committee has even
told the federal court
that it believes the
former president himself
could be criminally prosecuted
for his conduct leading up to,
and his actions on January 6, 2021.
But what are the potential crimes
that former President Trump
and his cadre might have
committed related to January 6?
Well, there are a lot of them,
and we're going to go
into detail for each one.
Now, this is not an exhaustive survey
since the one, six committee
isn't finished yet,
it's also fairly one-sided
because it is not a criminal prosecution
and it's not adversarial,
so it's one side's presentation.
Though many of the witnesses
are former Trump confidants,
so take that for what you will.
But in 2020, then President
Donald Trump was defeated
for reelection by former
Vice-President, Joe Biden
by a margin of 7 million
popular votes and account of 306
to 232 votes in the electoral college.
Since his lost, President Trump
has falsely insisted the
election was stolen from him
while repeating ridiculous
debugs conspiracy theories.
Now these false accusations were endorsed
by many Republican members of Congress
and supporters in the media.
Now between election day
and inauguration day,
President Trump and his allies sought
to overturn the results
by filing over 62 lawsuits
where they lost every single one,
but a tiny part of one case
involving proximity to ballots
and made repeated allegations
of election fraud in the news,
in social media, organized protests,
and tried to convince legislators
to take part in pressured
Georgia's secretary of state
to find enough votes to carry
that particular state.
In addition, 84 Republicans
signed legal documents,
falsely claiming to be
the duly chosen electors
for Donald Trump in the electoral college,
despite Trump having lost
in those particular states.
These include dozens of local
Republican party leaders,
seven candidates for public office,
eight current office holders,
and at least five previous state
and federal office holders.
This fake elector scheme was
led in part by Rudy Giuliani
and Trump lawyer, John Eastman,
the latter of whom penned
to now public memos
to pressure Vice-President Mike Pence
to overthrow the election results.
And on January 6, 2021,
a mob of Trump supporters
stormed to the US Capitol
to disrupt a joint session of Congress
that had convened to certify the results
of the 2020 election.
Prior to that attack,
President Trump encouraged the
large crowd of his supporters
near the White House to
March on the US Capitol
and fight like hell to resist
Congress's certification
of the Biden victory, which
many in the crowd did.
- [Crowd] USA, USA.
- And approximately 140 Capitol
and metropolitan police officers
were criminally assaulted
in the attack.
One died of a series of strokes
after being hospitalized
for his injury sustained in the attack,
and two others committed suicide.
One of the writers was shot
and killed by the police,
another died of a heart attack,
and a third was crushed to
death by the stampeding mob.
Writers caused about
1.5 million in damages
to the Capitol building
and in response to the
House of Representatives
with 10 Republican votes,
impeach Trump for
incitement of insurrection.
Mr. Trump was acquitted
after only 57 senators,
10 short of the required
two-thirds majority
voted to find him guilty.
And even after the carnage on January 6,
Trump continues to falsely claim
that the election was stolen from him.
- It's all over the place,
it's massive election Fraud.
- And in may of 2021 Senate
Republicans blocked the passage
of a house pass bill
that would've created
a national commission
to investigate the January 6th attack.
In response, the house voted
to create a select committee
to investigate the January
6th attack on the US Capitol,
speaker Pelosi rejected the appointments
of Republican representative,
Jim Jordan and Jim Banks
citing their objections
to the election results
on January 6, and raising concerns
that they would impact the
integrity of the investigation.
In response house minority
leader, Kevin McCarthy,
pulled all remaining
Republicans on the committee,
though Pelosi still named two impeachment,
supporting Republicans, Liz
Cheney and Adam Kinzinger
to serve on the select committee.
Now much of the past year
has involved the prosecution
of over 800 January 6th
writers with charges ranging
from obstruction of an
official proceeding assault
to seditious conspiracy.
But the January 6th hearings
are looking up the ladder
to see what crimes and to what extent
the Trump White House its allies,
and even Trump himself were
responsible for on that day.
So let's look at some of the
potential criminal violations
of Trump and his circle.
Now we first begin with
criminal conspiracy
to defraud the United States.
Under 18 U.S.C. 371, it
is a criminal offense,
"If two or more persons conspire,
either to commit any offense
against the United States
or to defraud the United
States or any agents thereof
in any manner or for any purpose."
The supreme court has held the
statute criminalizes the use
of deceptive practices in connection with,
"Any conspiracy, for the purpose
of impairing, obstructing,
or defeating the lawful function
of any department of government."
And conspiring to obstruct
a joint session of Congress
from certifying the election,
certainly qualifies as seeking
to obstruct a lawful function
of the government.
Now to convict someone of
defrauding the United States,
the government must
establish three elements.
One, at least two people
entered into an agreement
with the specific intent
to obstruct a lawful
function of government.
Two, the individuals used
deceitful or dishonest means
to accomplish this goal.
And three, at least one of
the conspirators engaged
in at least one overt act in
furtherance of the agreement.
And to establish the requisite
intent for this crime,
it's sufficient for the
prosecution to prove
that the defendant knew that
the statements were false
or fraudulent when made and
that such statements disrupted
the functions of the government.
Accordingly, the January 6th Committee
has laid out a seven
point plan for how Trump
and his allies orchestrated
to defraud the United States government.
One, they engaged in a considered effort
to spread false information
to the American public
that the 2020 election was stolen.
Two, they orchestrated a
corrupt scheme between Trump,
his chief of staff, Mark Meadows
and representative Scott Perry
to replace the acting attorney general
who rejected Trump's fraud claims
with Trump DOJ ally, Jeffrey Clark
to use the justice department
to overturn the election.
Three, they implemented a
plan by attorney John Eastman
into now public legal memos
to pressure Vice-President
Pence to refuse to count
or delay the certification
of the electoral count
despite Eastman's knowledge
that this violated federal law.
For they pressured
state election officials
and state legislators to
change election results,
like Trump's infamous January 2nd,
call to Georgia's secretary of
state, Bradford Raffensperger
to quote, "Find enough votes
to flip the state's results."
Five, they instructed Republicans,
including chief of staff, Mark Meadows,
acting at Trump's behest
in multiple states
to embrace Rudy Giuliani
and John Eastman's plan
to create a false electoral slate
in seven battleground states
and transmit those fake slates
to Congress and the national archives.
Six, they summoned assembled
and incited a violent mob
in Washington and directed them
to March on the US Capitol.
And seven, during the attack,
Trump ignored plead for assistance failed
to take immediate steps
to stop the violence
and even appeared to tacitly,
endorse the violence,
including threats to hang Mike Pence.
- [Woman] Pence is a traitor.
- [Woman] Traitor Pence, traitor Pence.
- Now, it appears that
the phony elector scheme
has caught the DOJs attention,
having issued subpoenas
to several individuals
who signed false certificates,
including the chairs of the Georgia
and Arizona Republican Party.
And in a March, 2022 crime
fraud exception ruling,
California, federal judge
David O. Carter found,
"It is more likely than not
that Trump and Eastman conspired
to defraud the United States
by corruptly attempting
to obstruct the counting
of electoral votes on January 6th."
But it remains to be seen whether the DOJ
will bring formal charges
against former President Trump
and his allies related to section 371,
but that takes us to obstructing
an official proceeding
of Congress under 18 U.S.C, 1512.
Now that criminalizes the obstruction
or attempted obstruction
of an official proceeding
with a maximum prison
sentence of 20 years.
To obtain a conviction,
prosecutors must establish
that the person obstructed
influence or impeded or attempted
to obstruct influence or
impede an official proceeding
of the United States and did so corruptly.
Courts have uniformly held
that the January 6th joint session
is an official proceeding,
and hundreds of Capitol
writers have been charged
with this crime.
And for many, this is the only felony
that they were charged with.
This includes Jacob Chansley,
the so-called QAnon
Shaman who pleaded guilty
to a single charge of corruptly impeding
an official proceeding and was sentenced
to 41 months in prison.
Now, the legal theory for prosecution
is that former president Trump in concert
with allies like Eastman,
Clark Meadows and others
intentionally or corruptly interfered
with Congress's certification
of electoral votes,
despite aggressive pushback
that not only were these plans illegal,
but that there was no reasonable basis
to doubt that Biden won.
Now, multiple members of Trump's
circle testified under oath
to the select committee
that they all told Trump
his claims of election
fraud were baseless,
including Attorney General Bill Barr,
Campaign Aide Jason Miller,
Mike Pence's former Chief
of Staff Marc Short,
and even his own daughter Ivanka.
And though Trump circle told
him his claims were baseless,
his supporters took those claims as gospel
to justify storming Capitol
to deny certification.
- I'm here to protest this corruption.
We wanna stop the deal,
we want a free election,
we want Donald Trump in office.
- The committee's first
hearing on January 9th
showed previous unseen footage
of writers, many whom said
they were following
President Trump's commands
to storm the Capitol
to block the certification of election,
they were told was stolen.
- And people are really pissed off
because we know how
much cheating took place
and if'd won fair and square,
I think we would be fine,
but we can't let them
overthrow our country.
- And the mob believing
these election lies
did successfully delay the
account for at least seven hours
by violently forcing both
chambers into recess and hiding.
Trump's reported obstruction scheme
also involves strong arming the DOJ
to overturn the election.
And contemporaneous notes of acting
Deputy Attorney General,
Richard Donoghue showed
that Trump asked him directly to,
"Say that the election was corrupt
and leave the rest to him, and
the Republican Congressman.
Suggesting that Trump didn't
want a good faith investigation,
just a DOJ declaring as cover
for throwing out Biden's
dually elected electoral votes.
And accordingly the select
committee has presented evidence
that Trump and others corruptly obstructed
an official proceeding by
advancing legal strategies.
They knew were unlawful
based on allegations
of election fraud,
and they had no reasonable basis
to believe that they were true.
But prosecution under
section 15, 12, depends
on how federal courts
interpret that statute.
In March of 2022 DC Judge Carl Nichols,
a Trump appointee who
has issued more lenient
January six sentences
compared to his colleagues
broke with at least seven
other DC federal judges
by ruling that the DOJ
cannot charge individuals
with obstructing Congress,
unless the defendant's actually tampered
with official documents
or records on January 6.
So this could potentially
impact hundreds of cases,
including the potential prosecution
of Trump and his circle.
And that takes us to
garden variety wire fraud.
Between election day
and leaving office on January 20th, 2021.
Then President Trump raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
for what he told supporters
was to contest the results.
There's just one, 250 million problem.
Trump raised millions for
an election defense fund
that may not actually exist.
Sometimes suggested
this could be wire fraud
under 18 U.S.C. 1343 wire fraud occurs
when someone uses interstate
communications devices
like a cell phone,
the computer or other electronic
device to advances scheme
to defraud another.
To prove wire fraud the government
has to establish four elements.
One, that the defendant voluntarily
and intentionally devised
or participated in a scheme
to defraud another out of money.
That the defendant did so
with the intent to defraud
that it was reasonably foreseeable
that interstate wire
communications would be used,
and that interstate wire
communications were in fact used.
To convict Trump of wire fraud prosecutors
would have to show that he
solicited funds for one purpose
and knowingly used them for another.
The January 13th hearing led
by Congresswoman Zoe Lofgren of California
showed that the campaign spent
very little of this money
on election contests.
And instead funneled the money
to among other destinations
Trump business properties
and his own Save America
political action committee.
This fundraising scheme might
potentially be fraudulent,
not just because it induced donations
with claims of voter fraud,
which Trump had been repeatedly informed
by the justice department and others
that they were baseless,
but also because the money did not go
to where people thought
it was going to go.
This would be a particularly
hard claim to prove,
but there is precedent
for prosecuting candidates
who raised money for fake organizations
and then spend the funds on themselves.
In 2019, Harold Russell
Taub, Rhode Island Republican
who ran unsuccessfully
against democratic Congressman
David Cicilline in 2016,
pleaded guilty to wire fraud
and campaign finance violations
in connection with a 1.6 million raise
for a non-existent
political action committee.
In the course of fundraising
Taub told his donors
that his PAC staff were volunteers
and that a hundred
percent of the donations
would be used to support
Republican candidates in Ohio
at the state and federal level.
In reality, the two PACs were unregistered
and Taub spent $1 million of those funds
on personal expenses.
Adding to the deception
Taub falsely told donors
that he was an ambassador and
also used without permission
a former secretary of the Navy
in his fundraising appeal,
despite being repeatedly told to stop.
Taub was sentenced to three
years in federal prison
in order to repay 1.1 million
that he made through his fraudulent PACs.
Now, ironically Trump's best
defense against wire fraud
would be to argue that
he sincerely did believe
that the funds would be used
to fight election contest.
And for the mercurial
and potentially sincere Donald Trump,
that could be a challenge for prosecutors.
But that takes us to criminal solicitation
to commit election fraud and
other Georgia state crimes.
Now it seems like Trump
is particularly vulnerable
to a litany of state charges in Georgia
where Fulton County District
Attorney Fani Willis
has convened a special grand
jury to investigate Trump
and his allies efforts to
pressure election officials
and change the vote count in Georgia.
By letter dated February
10th, 2021 DA Willis announced
that her office had, "Opened
an investigation into attempts
to influence the administration
of the 2020 general election."
And where Trump and his allies
probably find the most
potential criminal exposure
is Georgia Code Section 21-2-604,
the criminal solicitation
to commit election fraud,
which can be charged as either
a misdemeanor or felony.
And to establish a violation
under Section 21-2-604,
the DA has to show that
the defendant has one,
solicited, requested,
commanded, importuned,
or otherwise attempted
to cause another person
to engage in election fraud.
And two, the defendant actually intends
for the other person to
commit election fraud.
And at the center of this potential crime
are the two recorded phone calls
involving the president applying pressure
to state election
officials to flip the state
from Biden to himself.
First, on December 23rd, 2020,
Trump urged Francis Watson,
the chief election investigator
for Georgia's secretary
of state office, to
find fraud telling her,
"When the right answer comes
out, you'll be praised."
And second in the famous
January 2nd, 2021 recorded
phone call to Georgia secretary of state,
Brad Raffensperger, where
the former president
famously demanded that he,
"Find 11,780 votes,"
one more than Trump needed
to win in that state.
- [Trump] I just wanna find 11,780 votes,
which is one more than we have.
- When Ravensburger rejected
Trump's false claims
of voter fraud, like
the (indistinct) claim
that the Trump votes were thrown out,
while suitcases of votes were
carried in for Joe Biden,
Trump suggested Raffensperger
could face criminal charges,
telling him it would be illegal
and a big risk to
resolve against reporting
Trump's false claims.
Trump also implicitly
threatened other state officials
with jail time, and
continues to hold a grudge
against every Georgia elected official
who refuses his demands.
- So what are we gonna do here, folks?
I only need 11,000 votes, fellas.
I need 11,000 votes, give me a break.
- And in addition to criminal solicitation
of election fraud, DA Willis has indicated
that her officers' investigation involves
other potential violations
of Georgia law by Trump
and his associates, including,
but not limited to, "The
making of false statements
to state and local governmental bodies,"
that's Georgia Code Section 16-10-20.
Conspiring to commit election fraud,
that's Georgia Code Section 21-2-603.
Racketeering, Georgia
Code Section 16-14-4.
Violation of oath of
office, Section 16-10-1.
And any involvement in
violence or threats related
to the election administration.
That's Georgia Code
Section 21-2-566 and 597.
Now, illustrating the expanded
scope of the investigation,
the grand jury has subpoenaed
several key members
of the Trump legal team
that advised his campaign
on how to overturn
Biden's wins in Georgia,
and other swing states,
including John Eastman,
Cleta Mitchell, Kenneth Chesebro,
Jenna Ellis, and Rudy Giuliani,
who twice presented
Georgia state legislators
with fake evidence and
wild conspiracy theories,
even after they were debunked.
The grand jury has also
subpoenaed US Senator,
Lindsay Graham, who
twice asked Raffensperger
if there was any way to
throw out mail-in ballots,
which were favoring Joe Biden.
According to the subpoena,
Graham asked Raffensperger
and his staff, "about reexamining
certain absentee ballots cast in Georgia
in order to explore the possibility
of a more favorable outcome for Trump."
Describing the call to
CNN, Raffensperger said
the Senator was implying
that his office should try
to throw away ballots.
- I got the sense it implied
that then you could throw those out.
- But that takes us to another
potential federal charge,
which would be the incitement
to riot and insurrection.
Trump was acquitted of
incitement to insurrection
in his second impeachment trial,
but since that was not a judicial trial,
there's no double jeopardy problem,
and he could potentially face charges
on various incitement statutes.
Under the Anti-Riot Act
18 U.S.C. Section 2101,
anyone who uses interstate
travel to incite, organize,
participate in, or carry on a riot,
or commit any other act
of violence in furtherance
of a riot, or aid or abet
a person doing the above
is guilty of a federal crime punishable
by up to five years in prison.
And under Section 18 U.S.C. 2383,
anyone who incites, assists,
or engages in any rebellion
or insurrection against the
authority of the United States,
or gives aid or in comfort there too
is subject to up to 10
years in imprisonment
and disqualification from
holding public office.
Now, conviction under
either of these statutes
would be incredibly difficult,
because political speech tends
to be at the very core
of the First Amendment,
and you generally have
a First Amendment right
to make these kinds of speeches.
But in Brandenburg versus Ohio,
the Supreme Court
established a two-part test
for when the government may
criminalize speech advocating
for the use of force or crime.
One, the speech is directed to inciting
and producing imminent lawless action,
and the speech is likely to
incite or produce such action.
And it would be incredibly fraught to try
to prove that Trump intended
to incite imminent lawless
action on January 6th.
Though many writers did say on
and after January 6th that
they marched on the Capitol,
specifically because Trump told them to.
- I'm here to support the president,
I think the election was a fraud.
- And with respect to the second criteria,
the committee has presented evidence
that Trump not only incited
the mob to go to the Capitol,
but Trump endorsed the
violence of the people he saw
when they were there on his behalf.
Cassidy Hutchinson, the
former aid to chief of staff.
Mark Meadows provided bombshell testimony
that Trump was aware that
many people outside his rally
were armed with knives,
guns in the form of pistols,
and rifles, bear spray, body
armor, spears and flag poles.
And he didn't care because
they were, "my people."
Hutchinson further testified
that she heard Trump say
something to the effect of,
"I don't (beep) care
that they have weapons,
they're not here to hurt me.
Take the (beep) mags,
the magnetometers and
metal detectors away.
Let my people in, they can
March on the Capitol from here.
Let the people in, take
the (beep) mags away."
And Hutchinson also testified
that when Trump was told
about the writers' hang Mike Pence chants,
Trump approvingly responded,
"Maybe our supporters have the right idea,
Mike Pence deserves it."
Now, furthermore, the Joint Chiefs'
Chairman General Mark Milley testified
that Pence ordered National Guard troops
to defend the Capitol, while
Trump allowed the violence
to continue unabated.
We also know that Trump waited 187 minutes
before putting out a
statement asking for calm.
Now, it was always going to
be a long shot to charge Trump
with incitement, though the testimony
that has been elicited
so far probably comes
as close as you might be able to get.
And multiple sources say that
Trump had actual knowledge
that his speech was going
to incite his supporters,
particularly the armed
ones to go to the Capitol
before Trump allowed the
violence to rage for three hours.
So who knows here?
But that takes us to
two potential new crimes
that were uncovered,
witness tampering and
obstruction of justice.
Many people say it's not
the crime, it's the coverup,
and that may be the case here as well.
After Hutchinson's testimony,
Trump ex chief of staff,
Mick Mulvaney, suggested on Twitter
that his former boss could be vulnerable
to witness tampering and
obstruction of justice.
So what would that entail?
Well, 18 U.S.C. 15, 12, the same statute
that includes obstruction
of an official proceeding,
broadly criminalizes witness tampering
with up to 20 years imprisonment.
This section makes it a crime for anyone
who knowingly uses intimidation, threats,
or otherwise attempts to
persuade another person
to change, delay, or prevent testimony,
or any person in an official proceeding.
After Hutchinson's testimony,
the select committee produced
examples of witnesses
being asked by people
apparently close to Trump
to be loyal to him and his administration.
Representative Liz Cheney
said an unnamed witness told
the committee, "What they
said to me is, as long
as I continue to be a team player,
they know I'm on the right team,
I'm doing the right thing,
I'm protecting who I need to protect.
You know, I'll continue to stay
in good graces in Trump World.
And they have reminded
me a couple of times
that Trump does read the transcripts."
And the second example Cheney cited
was a call a witness received saying,
"A person, let me know you
have your deposition tomorrow.
He wants me to let you know,
he's thinking about you.
He knows you're loyal,
and you're going to do the right thing
when you go in for your deposition."
The select committee has suggested
there are many more
examples of similar efforts
to influence witnesses.
And with respect to obstruction
of justice, 18 U.S.C. 1505,
that criminalizes the act or the attempt
to corruptly influence, obstruct,
or impede a congressional investigation
through threats, force,
or threatening
communications, with a penalty
of up to five years imprisonment.
Now, corruptly means acting
with an improper purpose,
personally, or by influencing another,
including making a false
or misleading statement,
or withholding, concealing, altering,
or destroying a document
or other information.
And before her public
appearance, Hutchinson told
the committee that
several Republican members
of the far-right House
Freedom Caucus asked
for preemptive blanket
pardons for themselves
and others in connection
with their efforts
to overturn the election,
including Representatives
Mo Brooks, Matt Gaetz,
Andy Biggs, and Louie
Gohmert and Scott Perry.
Hutchinson also said Jim Jordan asked
for an update on presidential pardons
without asking for one directly,
and she heard from another staffer
that Marjorie Taylor Green
had asked for a pardon.
These preemptive pardon
requests could be an effort
to induce those involved, or are witnesses
to criminal conduct to remain silent,
which even with a president's
nearly unlimited pardon power
might constitute criminal violations.
Hutchinson also told the
committee that she witnessed
Meadows burn documents after
a meeting in his office
with Representative Scott Perry,
and the destruction of documents,
coupled with Perry's request
for a pardon might suggest
the pair understood that they
were doing something illegal,
which could be evidence
of witness tampering,
and/or obstruction of justice.
And that takes us to seditious conspiracy.
At the first hearing of
the select committee,
Representative Cheney
declared that the committee
will detail plots to
commit seditious conspiracy
on January 6th.
Now, this is among the most
serious of crimes alleged
with sedation, essentially
being just a step below treason.
To convict individuals
of seditious conspiracy
under 18 U.S.C. 2384,
prosecutors would have
to establish that at
least two people conspired
to use force to overthrow the government,
oppose its authority, or
subvert the execution of US law.
These charges are understandably rare,
but they were brought against some members
of the far-right Oath
Keepers and Proud Boys,
including their former
Chairman Enrique Tarrio,
for conspiring to use armed
force to violently oppose
the peaceful transfer
of presidential power.
So what might seditious
conspiracy charges against Trump
or his circle look like?
Well, after the first
meeting, committee chair,
Representative Benny Thompson
told CNN that witnesses
had described conversations
between far-right extremists
and Trump's circle...
And direct communications
with Oath Keepers and Proud
Boys could be concrete evidence
of White House involvement
in the same crimes.
It's hard to say we haven't
seen that evidence yet.
So just conspiracy
might also involve Trump
and his allies allowing the violence
to continue to pressure Pence.
(indistinct) to the president's demands
to not certify the results.
In fact, days after the attack,
we learned that Trump and
Rudy Giuliani had urged
at least one GOP Senator
to stall the proceedings
while the violence unfolded.
Though there are certainly
not a lot of examples
of successful seditious
conspiracy prosecutions
in the last 100 years.
Though in 1995, Sheikh Omar Abdel-Rahman,
a prominent Muslim clerk and
nine others, were convicted
of seditious conspiracy for planning
to bomb the New York City landmarks
after the 1993 World Trade Center bombing.
Conspiracy charges have been difficult
to make stick, particularly
against far-right groups,
given the Brandenburg
protection of illegal advocacy
without imminent lawless action.
But by May, 2022, three Oath
Keepers had pleaded guilty
to those charges.
And if these defendants
cooperated in their plea deals,
it might shed light on whether members
of the Trump White House
and his circle could face
their own seditious conspiracy charges.
And while some might go to jail,
others just might get house arrest.
In which case, their options
for nice, home-cooked
meals would be limited,
but not with today's sponsor, HelloFresh.
HelloFresh is a great way to
eat delicious, fresh food,
while still being healthy,
even if you have been
indicted for federal crimes.
In fact, HelloFresh has a whole variety
of calorie-smart and carb-smart recipes,
as well as pescatarian and veggie options.
You can customize it how
you'd like, swap out proteins,
get premium top-of-the-line versions.
HelloFresh delivers fresh quality produce
from the farm to your
door in less than a week,
so you can savor these
summer flavors right
from home at peak freshness.
Now, I'm a do-it-yourself person,
I have to say I was very
skeptical when I first heard
of HelloFresh, 'cause
I'm a pretty good cook,
so I didn't think that I
really needed the help,
but I actually loved it.
Even for an experience cook,
HelloFresh delivers new ingredients
and recipes that I'd never try on my own.
HelloFresh generally keeps
everyone's favorite meals,
then rotates new ones in all the time.
Right now, they're running
their Taste to the Summer series
with things like old bay
shrimp and sausage boil,
family-style grilled steak lettuce wraps,
or grilled salmon with balsamic tomatoes.
Now, I don't know about you,
but I'd never attempt
any of those on my own.
And of course, everything was
delivered straight to my door,
so I didn't even have to do any shopping.
The produce actually gets too
faster than a grocery store,
so it arrives with peak freshness.
And it's also super easy to save time,
because HelloFresh cuts out
the meal planning and prep,
so the recipes only take
20 to 30 minutes to cook.
Literally less time to cook
than it would normally take
to do the shopping itself.
And it's also very sustainable.
Since the ingredients are proportion,
there's less prep and less wasted food,
and the packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable
or already recycled content,
HelloFresh's carbon footprint
is actually 25% less
than that of meals made
from store by groceries,
and it's 72% cheaper than
dining at a restaurant.
So if you'd like to try HelloFresh,
and I recommend that you at least try it,
you can go to hellofresh.com,
and use the code LEGALEAGLE16
for up to 16 free meals
and three surprise gifts.
Yes, you can actually get 16 free meals,
and that includes free shipping,
or you can just click on the link below.
So again, for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts,
go to hellofresh.com and
use the code LEGALEAGLE16,
or just click on the link below,
or the one that's on screen right now.
And clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So click on this link, or click
on this playlist over here
for more Legal Eagle, where
I will see you in court.